this is a production of cornell
university
uh thank you for the introduction jenny
and also the invitation to be part of
part of this presentation this morning
it's been a great opportunity to really
work with feed management
over the years
and be able to present some of the
findings that we we found with
improvements in the water quality and
also looking at you know
our opportunities to look at
maybe expanding this for for greenhouse
gas emissions and also
talk a little bit about you know how do
we how do we get nutritionists or
others to become tsps to write these
nutrients or the feed management plans
so
they're going to talk a little bit today
about uh you know what feed management
is our
our implementation of it and then
again moving to how we're seeing it fit
more into greenhouse gas mitigation and
then close up with some
assistance for both producers and
and our
tsps or
certified nutritionists so
i've used this slide many times
in working with jenny ishler from penn
state university
but
one of the biggest things is you know
when it comes to manipulating feed is
especially when it comes to the manure
is
you know we can do a lot of work just
through adjusting feed formulations for
for poultry and livestock
and
anything from adjusting protein values
uh
phosphorus inclusion in the ration and
also
looking at as as kristen mentioned uh
looking at the digestibility of
of the fiber within that forage
component so you know this is something
as you can see in the date on them
on the reference you know
going even back to 2004 you know this
has been a topic that has been looked at
uh for for many years and i think we're
going to still continue to look at it
for for the years to come
next slide
so we talk about a little bit about
planning or applying feed management and
uh so every every five years the nrcs
standard for each of our conservation
practices gets updated and then each
state has an opportunity to take that
national standard
and tailor it to their needs for each
state so just want to show where we've
gone uh in history from when i got
started with feed management the prior
to 2018
what you'll see here is and this comes
directly from our our feed management
practice standard for for our practice
592
and prior to 2018 you know we were
looking at
a lot of using feed management to
impact manure management so where where
would we talk to producers about
applying this this this practice so we
were looking at whole farm imbalances so
think about poultry farms think about
your large dairy operations your capo
operations you know they produce a lot
of manure
can have high phosphorus content so
they're producing more phosphorus than
what the third land can support through
land application
and also the soil nutrient buildup
as we know in traditional farms one of
the most expensive costs of dealing with
that manure generated is hauling that
and getting it applied on the field so a
lot of fields
usually closer to the headquarters
receive those nutrients so then you
start seeing the buildup of nutrients
in the soil closer to the farm and then
the land base not large enough so again
not enough acres total to
to apply that land and you think about
lancaster county here in pennsylvania
you know
rental prices for cropland are very very
expensive and i haven't looked
recently but in past years you know
farmers are paying four five six seven
hundred dollars an acre to rent land so
yeah so and as
uh urbanization expands we're losing
more cropland so of course then that
land becomes at a premium and you know
look at the poultry industry on the
delmarva peninsula you know a lot of
nutrients build and there's just not
enough land to apply those nutrients
and then our catch-all was you know
using feed management seeking to enhance
nutrient efficiency that looking at
feed efficiency
nitrogen efficiency and how the the
rations could be manipulated
so
next slide
so
currently with the the standard that
we're working under
you know it got tweaked a little bit but
the biggest thing that i wanted to point
out here
is you know
our folks at national
you know really said
saul that you know there was an iss
there is an issue with
uh how we're how nutritionists are are
balancing rations and how producers are
choosing to feed their animals um you
know and not taking into account milk
production levels or or growth growth
rates and we're seeing crude protein and
phosphorus formulated above uh
recommendations either by the nutrient
or the national research council or the
local land-grant
university
but what i want to point out here is is
item number five where you know we kept
that ability
that ability to use it to increase our
nutrient efficiencies but then we've
we've entered into
the greenhouse gas mitigation uh arena
so
so even here at nrcs we're seeing that
you know there's a lot of opportunity
that that feed management can provide to
mitigating water quality concerned as
well as greenhouse gas
so in looking at you know i mentioned
feed efficiency so feed efficiency is
looking at you know how much is being
fed
to those to those grazings um
those
to those animals and also taking into
account
milk production or meat production from
those from those animals so you know
looking at
how we're feeding the animals what are
the impacts to to the ecosystem so from
the water quality side of things
you know if we can use feed management
to look at our rations we can reduce
that phosphorus loading
uh within the soil
we can also look at reducing our
nitrogen loading whether it's through
you know ammonia nitrous oxide
you know reducing odor
reducing the amount of manure produced
so again one of the things that you're
going to see coming up is part of what
we did through feed management is
tracking dry matter intakes and you know
matching it how is those intakes
compared to
what the rations were formulated for as
terms of milk production and also
what milk production was actually being
recorded
and also the volume of purchase feed our
our program really
focused on
looking at using high high digestible
feeds high quality feeds
in order to
make these nutrient reductions
and also uh what we found over time is
you know through implementing a feed
management plan
you know
looking at
how much is being fed the quality of the
feeds there was often an opportunity but
not but not always but a lot of
opportunity to increase that bottom line
so as we as we continued with our feed
management program we started tracking
income over feed costs
on our on our lactating herds just so
producers would have an
op
the ability to see
how the changes they were making within
their feed management program
or
potentially helping their bottom line
you know on the other side of things you
know with feed management
as i just mentioned from the greenhouse
gas side of things you know obviously if
we're looking at the crude protein in
the rations formulating those uh closer
to production levels we're going to make
an impact on our our n2o or emissions
we're also looking at you know we can
increase milk production per feed
you know how much we're being fed so if
we're increasing our feed efficiency by
looking at our forages and our forage
digestibility
we're going to re reduce we can reduce
dry matter intakes which obviously is
going to equal less manure coming out
coming out the back end and again you
know looking at our nitrous oxide and in
methane production
again if we can reduce the amount of
feed that's needed overall
again by looking at our digestibilities
and overall intakes
you know
can we have the
the reduction in in the greenhouse gas
emissions that are coming from the
equipment through um you know their the
crop production process
and also you know again if we're feeding
if we're feeding less feeding a higher
quality feed we're going to make more
milk and you know looking at how the
dairies dairy industry has been over the
past five years you know
i can't think of any dairy farms off the
top of my head that couldn't use a way
to
increase
profit and in meeting break evens and
and
continue to be sustainable within their
community
next slide
so some of the
things you see you know obviously you
know we work for
usda the government we like to use
alphabet so i want to take a little bit
if i go through some of the definitions
there of the abbreviations you might see
through through my presentation so
anytime you see dmi that's our dry
matter intake in terms of pounds per day
as as christian alluded to ecm is energy
corrected milk fcm is fat corrected milk
cp is crude protein
you'll see some values where we're
tracking
bulk tank so bulk tank is that that
storage unit where milk is stored on the
farm and also when that milk gets picked
up there is a test done by the
cooperative to give the components as
far as the the butter fat the protein
of that milk so we use those values and
also farmers that do participate through
the testing program through the dhia
which is the gary herd information
system so just want to give you a quick
point out so as you see these
abbreviations might help you understand
the slides a little bit better
so what what is the impact of a feed
management plan on those nutrients so
i gave you a lot of verbal information
about that just over the past couple of
minutes so uh our next slide is going to
kind of give show you some of the
numbers and you know this is something
that um
again through jenny ishler just by
looking at some of the data
uh that she's had over the years and
also looking how how they've managed
the
the milk the lactating herd at penn
state
you know you can clearly see that even
if we're formulating for 80 pounds of
milk you know just by
managing and trying to
increase your dry matter intake
efficiency
just by yeah going from 54 pounds down
to 50 and then holding everything else
true as far as your percent your fat and
your protein from your components
the biggest thing is
looking at your annual manure production
you know that's where it's looking where
we can really use our feed efficiency
and tracking of our dry matter intakes
to make it to make an impact on manure
produced per cow
and then looking at the farm what is our
annual manure production
and then
and so the point of this slide is
essentially showing you know how much
less manure can be produced on the farm
just by managing
and looking to improve
dry matter intake efficiency so the last
column showing you that you know based
on on energy corrected milk per
dry matter intake you can see that just
by affecting that
making those reductions our our
efficiency has increased from 1.5 to 1.6
some people may say well that doesn't
seem like a a big issue but again when
you start think
thinking back to the purposes of why
we're doing feed management
and we don't have the land base large
enough
you know just the simple management of
dry matter intakes
can make a great impact on that
next slide
so
as i mentioned before what we added to
our program
as we progressed through the years was
tracking that that income over feed cost
so again you know
looking at uh
the milk production again holding
components steady
just by adjusting
those dry matter intakes or improving
dry matter intakes again through
forge testing you know increased forge
digestibility
we're making a a big change on our our
overall feed efficiency
and then starting to track your income
over feed costs as term as in terms of
you know dollars per cow per day
you know we're making almost a you can
help to
hopefully achieve an increase of almost
a dollar
per head per day
just from managing
the deficiency
and
you know and that's one thing again that
you're going to see it as i continue
that you know
some of the some of the opportunities on
the farm
that from the producers that
participated in our program
you know by the end we're starting to
see
the benefits of doing that and uh but we
also have our challenges and there's
also farmers that
resist change as you may know and then
also we had some resistance from
nutritionists to
really want to go out and make changes
because again
in the nutrition world out there it's uh
it can be a pretty tough business and if
you lose milk production you know
farmers
first person they want to look at is
your nutritionist so that was one of the
things that we that we found was some
were
hesitant to to make a lot of change
just because of that looming thought in
the back of their mind so
but moving to the next slide you know
where we're looking at our our nitrogen
again and this is looking at excretion
uh amounts per cow again looking at our
our feed efficiency changes so just by
managing our dry matter intakes
uh
we're making a reduction in overall
nitrogen excreted uh so
looking in in the last couple in the
last two columns you're seeing that you
know we're increasing we're almost
reducing
more
nitrogen excretion we're doubling that
can i say that doubling the reduction
uh
from
800 pounds to
1600 pounds and again
you know tracking that the
the opportunities through increasing
feed efficiency so
you know it just these these couple
slides just say you know it and this is
just one part of of the feed management
program but again
it's one thing that a lot of producers
take for granted um you know and that so
again you're gonna see
where just by them participating in our
program having a feed management plan
they were able to see
those numbers up front on a quarterly
basis
okay next slide
so phosphorus yeah that was what we here
in pennsylvania nrcs focused on heavily
with this because again we were we were
looking at water quality impacts and
reducing the amount of phosphorus you
know obviously
over half of the state of pennsylvania
flows into the chesapeake bay watershed
and into the chesapeake bay which
obviously is a target for nutrient
reduction so
uh you know we were seeing phosphorus as
an easy target to
to look at through feed management and
making these making these reductions so
again you know looking at just managing
dry matter intakes
and
improving that feed efficiency
we're seeing that we can again make a a
rather large change on that um
on that feed efficiency
so
slide
so what we were looking at doing through
our feed management program again
talked a lot about these dry matter
intakes and part of our of our program
in the system that had to be tracked on
a quarterly on a quarterly basis was to
track the actual amount of feed
presented to
to the cows
and then also track the formulated
levels so again i just saw a comment pop
up about
the feed that wasn't fed so
that's a lot of times
what a lot of farmers don't do is they
don't account for
you know their refusals and and through
our tracking sheets that was one thing
that we required was we were looking at
what was formulated what was presented
to the cow and we also wanted them to go
if there were refusals we wanted those
collected and weighed so we could act
get a true track
on that dry matter
dry matter intake so that's why we were
looking at our the ration coming from
the nutritionist and comparing it to the
batch weights and the feeding records
that we were requiring the producers to
to keep
so then you know obviously we're able to
correlate our actual feed intake to our
production levels you know again
looking at you know what kind of changes
were we seeing
improvements were we seeing when we were
able to achieve
you know a six pound improvement in dry
matter reduction in dry matter intake
you know so just by you know going by
six pounds you know
it had a great impact on our feed cost
and as you see from the previous slides
obviously that makes a a tremendous
impact on the volumes of manure
generated
and also
the point that i made throughout the
years uh
meeting with producers meeting with some
of our certified plan writers is you
know obviously if we can reduce the
amount of excess feed consumed
we're going to make a big improvement on
the excess manure generated
by those by the animals that are under
that
under our
our program so and again uh working with
jenny ishler and rob goodling from penn
state we had a nice spreadsheet out
there where we could track our intake
efficiency
and our feed efficiencies
uh to use those numbers to kind of track
you know what kind of improvements we're
making so you know we required milk
production components from built from
bulk tank data or if they were under
test from dhi
they could use that information
and again you know looking at our
calculated dry matter intake so if there
were refusals we were looking at farmers
to report those numbers
to the nutritionist so in the plan we
could come up with that a more accurate
idea of what a true
dry matter intake was
for those for those groups of cows under
contract
slide
so for tracking our protein again we
were collecting that milk production
data
you know anything that we could get from
bulk tank reports co-op data dhi reports
and essentially we
we also looked at muns
because that was a great way to track
nitrogen efficiency through the cow and
again as we were moving forward to
considering what we could do as far as
improvements to air quality
you know obviously if we could track
protein supplementation to mun's um
that gave us a good idea of you know
what's going to happen with with nitrous
oxide and ammonia emissions so
some of the sideboards that we had set
for our program was you know we were
looking for throughout
the animals throughout the groups
milking string
uh through our
that were in our plans were under
contract you know
our goal was
we wanted those farms to maintain mun
levels between eight to twelve
and if they you know obviously there's
going to be spikes from quarter to
quarter so
you know normalizing that you know as
long as we were seeing that trend that
was okay if we saw
them increasing each quarter then that
was one thing that that was brought up
to the nutritious and the farmer
something that you know why was that
happening what needed in them we wanted
to see changes on
on
rations and
and that on how those numbers could
start ticking back down though
um
for those tests that uh for those
producers that were on tests with dhi
we wherever we could get that mun data
uh we we pulled it and we required
copies to be submitted to us as part of
the record keeping
and then like i mentioned before we
would calculate our our milky nitrogen
efficiency
just by taking that that dry matter
intake
and those
records for bulk tank those production
values from their components and then
you know obviously to cut to calculate
that we're looking at our dry matter
intakes
to
protein levels our milk production and
overall protein production
in in the milk itself
next slide
and then with rash and phosphorus this
one
again we're tracking the actual amount
that was in the ration what was
presented to the kale and then how what
phosphorus levels were formulated within
the ration on paper and essentially
where we were unique compared to some of
our other states is we required fresh
fecal samples so none of our manure
samples came from a manure storage
our producers were
were required to submit uh direct grab
samples so yes we did have uh
nutritionists gloving up and grabbing
fresh fresh samples from those cows and
again we sent those out for analysis and
then we would compare
the phosphorus levels in the manure to
do book values and then
then looked at how how the rations were
formulated
to meet animal requirements and then
essentially
looking at adjusting those
i just want to show some of the on a
select farm uh you know obviously we had
a wide wide range of results
so you know we did have some farms that
were pretty linear across the time
but we had some farms make make great
improvements over time so what this
slide is representing is uh the blue
bars are your pounds of
phosphorus fecal phosphorus
from our tests and then the orange bars
are the book values so
what from our penn state agronomy guide
what was the book value that you know so
milk
a a milk cow was expected to manure was
expected to test at four pounds of
phosphorus
and then
you know what we were looking at at
tracking again was the amount of the
grams of phosphorus in that ration
itself so and a snapshot at the
beginning of each each year
that it was under plan you can see the
overall trend you know from the
benchmark time with the milk cows
you know they
they were supplementing
over 80 grams of phosphorus to that milk
milk cow which was resulting in almost
nine and a half pounds of p205 in that
manure but the take home messages you
can see that throughout the years you
know just by ration manipulation
we were able to
make those achieve those reductions and
this particular farm you know also
enrolled their dry cow and heifer group
and you can also see that
through that
we were able to adjust those those
rations and
so
and this is so i took that same farm
took the data to look at you know over
all 12 quarters so
they enrolled for five for
three years to track this so again our
green bars are the the pounds of fecal
phosphorus blue bars obviously our book
value
and then our yellow line represents the
grams of um phosphorus
that that showed up in the t from the
tmr analysis and then the red was how it
was formulated in the ration
so again for our lactating cows
this trend pretty much followed the same
and you can see you know one thing to
point out is as rash and phosphorus
changed we did see that there was a
direct correlation to what was being
excreted so you look at quarters 11 and
12
you know for whatever reason there was
there was an uptick in in formulated
levels
and
what was actually showing up in the from
the test results and there was an
increase over in those last quarters so
so that led us to believe that you know
just by
monitoring and making changes in
phosphorus formulation within the
diet direct correlation to how much was
being excreted by the cows
so our next slide is going to show the
dry cows
again a little more
a little more variable across the time
but our overall trend as far as pounds
of fecal p
uh phosphorus in terms of water quality
and we were
making achievements because you see that
overall trend is down again dry cows
usually don't have the same amount of
attention to detail sometimes
as the lactating ration and also your
heifers
you know so we do see a lot of
variability in these other groups and
one thing that
that jenny and i had started looking at
over time was you know how much of this
is related to
forage quality so obviously the milk
cow's always got good
good quality forage and then you know if
you're a farmer or producer you know
there's always the dry cow hay or the
heifer hay and that was the not so good
stuff and you know we have some ideas
but um you know as one that was another
thing we wish to do uh down the road but
uh
at this time it's it's not something we
were able to look at but
overall now this is taking uh the farm
in general taking all three groups
and just saying that
off you know so trying to look at the
overall impact of the farm as far as
phosphorus contributions
uh in the manure and it's potential
on intake
you know what we just wanted to show
here is yes through you know
even though there's variability between
the groups and the different quarters
again uh the the ability to make a great
improvement in in phosphorus uh
uh excretions
are are achievable again just through
just through
uh
are
rational evaluations and adjustments
by by those nutritionists
uh so i want to show a little bit about
the efficiency tracking as i talked
about again
we were taking bulk tank where we were
getting our values from so uh one thing
that we did find was you know some farms
have a high group and a low group
however there's only one bulk tank so
it was it was hard to
get great values because again
um you know
you got two different group production
groups going into the tank so um
yeah so we had to do the best that we
could so in in in this particular on
this particular farm which is different
than the graphs that i showed before you
know that nutritionist took a stab at um
coming up with some values that he felt
was representative of what he what we
would see from the high group versus the
low group but overall looking at our
milk production our component
values and then taking
comparing that to dry matter intakes you
can see that over time you know again
there's there's
this farm in particular was doing a
pretty good job from
from start to finish but you can see a
farm that's that has an almost 1.8
uh
intake efficiency
in my opinion that's pretty darn good
for a farm um
and then even in our our nitrogen
efficiency
uh we're we're seeing that anything over
30 percent
is is good you know if we if we could
get those nitrogen efficiencies over 35
uh
that's a pretty good operating farm as
well so
again so that's why we were tracking
that and again that was another tool
that we could present to the farmer to
show what the impacts were of the
feeding program and the changes that he
or she was making to their to their
feeding program
so
moving into our the the greenhouse gas
side of things so taking what we've
learned from our what our implementation
for water quality improvement
where could we take our program
in the future to help out with
greenhouse gases so again
thinking about the overall
feeding management program so that's
anything from ration formulation
producing the feeds acquiring the feeds
you know there's great opportunity
throughout the farm so again
from from the system area side of things
you know again feed production so again
you know those greenhouse gas emissions
from equipment
running to
to produce those those crops uh import
crops to the feed
again our feed production so again our
nitrogen use in terms of crude protein
or crop production
as far as nitrogen used to produce those
crops because obviously we do have lost
utilization prior to violence
volatilization
and
leaching and then also the nitrogen or
the crude protein and the ration and as
as
kristen really uh referred to in her her
presentations again you know that feed
efficiency within the rumen
uh that breakdown
and then also the feed efficiency and as
far as the manure management looking at
how much manure was being generated
based on those intakes
so again looking at what can be done on
the farm
you know where where could we
essentially see um
you know those greenhouse gases so
obviously we're seeing carbon dioxide
from field from
fossil fuel use to produce the crops uh
those those nitrous oxide emissions from
field crops and manure and then also as
as jenny talked about earlier the cow
burps the the methane produced from from
that rumen
the digestion of the forages within the
room and and obviously you know when
we're storing manure
uh we're generating methane as well so
next
so talk a little bit about the nutrient
cycle uh
and this is something that i've kind of
looked at over the past couple of years
and and have had some ideas
of where we could you know help fix that
cycle both for water quality side
and and the
greenhouse gas side thing so you know
when you think about the farm
feed products so again our midwest
grains byproduct
ingredients those
leave the importation of off farm
nutrients so we're importing
these grains from the midwest we're
importing these by-product feeds from
different parts of the state different
parts of the country and again that's
what we're finding is leading
um you know
the accumulation of off-farm nutrients
so again when we're talking about
land-based not large enough looking at
how how we're going to utilize these
nutrients you know again feed management
has a great impact on
on how we can adjust that
and again looking specifically at
phosphorus you know a lot of byproducts
are used uh in the in our rations again
because they they uh are a cheap or a
cheaper feed source but again we lose
quality and uh it's not
a lot of times those those byproduct
feeds lack the high quality that we need
for those efficiencies and believe it or
not there still are a lot of farms that
are bringing in organic phosphorus
whether it's through uh dykal or mono
calcium phosphate
we have worked with other other
companies other other researchers that
you know
we're not quite sure why there is
there's still this uh thought that you
know phosphorus is related to production
but
we can see that almost every ration out
there there's enough phosphorus coming
from either the grains or the other
ingredients that
still not quite sure why why inorganic
supplements are still being used but
again
that's a simple way to make a reduction
at the farm
and then also you know we're looking at
our our ammonia
and
nitrogen emissions you know derived from
those protein supplements so again
looking at how those crude protein
levels are formulated based on
uh production so
again that's why we tracked muns
you know really looked at dry matter
intakes and production because
again some nutritionists have theories
on
how much protein you need in the debt in
the diet to make components how much you
need for actual milk production but we
retract again we were tracking our muns
and our nitrogen our m e
so we could actually get a good handle
on
hey what's the effect of of these of the
slope limitation on efficiencies and
again start correlating that too
to air quality issues
next slide
so again looking at you know our
nitrogen sources need to be considered
whether it's alfalfa in the rations
additional protein you know
sometimes when we were seeing spikes in
in in
mun levels you know start looking at the
amount of soybean meal in those rations
and other other protein sources you know
a lot of times you know again you know
we had to look at reality too uh most as
christian as christian mentioned you
know corn silage alfalfa halage lead the
major components of these dairy rations
and obviously there's sometimes that if
there's not good manage bunk management
or silo management we had farms that
would run out of corn silage and the
only thing they had to feed was alfalfa
haylage and then they were trying to
balance things so again
now you're going to a
a
a forge it
you know depends on how it's made has
digestibility issues and again now
you're increasing protein so
you know our we were looking at you know
where should dairy rations be formulated
so you know we were seeing some
formulated between 15 and a half to over
18 percent crude protein
and again for these one group herds
so where they weren't breaking out high
cows versus locales
you know how were they formulating those
those rations was the protein being
formulated for those high producers
or was it being formulated for the
average those average cows
and again you know looking at the excess
protein you know again
you know that comes as a form of urea
nitrogen
as far as your ambulance and your and
your buns
and also the ammonia so again tracking
that nitrogen efficiency through the cow
gives us a good idea of what's what's
going on with those with those fractions
next slide
so again looking at enteric methane
looking at the cal burps
and how our rations are formulated and
this is where you'll see a little bit of
difference between christian slides and
what i'm going to present you know
obviously the one thing i want to point
out is you know
enteric methane is a naturally occurring
process within the rumen so there's no
way to ever cut out
methane production you're never going to
really
eliminate cow burps they're always going
to be there but again
as kristin mentioned you know we can
look at the amount of forage in the diet
but i really want to point out is you
know the quality of the forge in the
diet
what can be done what can those what can
our producers do to really monitor the
quality of the forage that's being fed
so again biggest thing is formulating
for the correct nutritional or
physiological status
of those animals so again
what we're finding is there's more
opportunity and i think even for air
quality you know if we can split those
milking groups based on production high
groups low groups
average groups
again sometimes not always feasible
based on barn space and how the barns
are set up but again it's something to
talk to the producers about that can
make
an impact on their farm
you know again splitting our dry cows
based on pregnancy status so i had a
a few farms that were managing far off
dry cows versus the close-up truck house
others one big group of dry cows and
obviously
that led to some problems and how
rations are being formulated because
you know we know the nutritional needs
between those those two groups of of dry
cows and then you know
also you know
where you're talking about balance
valuing the forage quality for growing
heifers as you mentioned you know you
talk to a lot of farms you hear it oh
dry cow hay heifer hay you know it's
like it's the stuff that gets rained on
is that but again
you know if we're looking at making an
overall impact on the farm
you know we have to value
the the forage quality that's being fed
on on the farm and trying to make
improvements
of that forage quality throughout the
year being produced by the farm
so what we're finding i think uh should
be kind of apparent by now but uh you
know we're finding that
plans that in the style of plan that
we've implemented over the years we
definitely have the potential to
make this switch in from water quality
to
greenhouse gases because again the way
that our our monitoring tool or excel
spreadsheet was set up you know it was
it's easy for us to monitor
those dry matter intakes through the
cows
we could easily add in you know looking
at what's the percentage of forage in
the rations is it 50 50 is it 70 30. you
know again
there's those two camps yes we can
reduce forage in the diet and increase
concentrates but
to achieve uh
methane reductions but what's the effect
on the bottom line and is it truly
just shaking a change in the forge or is
it by trying to increase digestibility
of those forages so
and again
we require quarterly testing of the
forages and the rations so every quarter
they needed to test tmrs if they were
component fed herd they had to test
each each component of that ration
but one thing that we're finding is if
we're really looking at trying to make a
an impact on on that enteric methane
and those cow burps you know
uh really talking to the farmer about
forge testing frequency and these
what i call the add-on test those
optional tests that cost more
that usually don't get run but again
a lot a lot of producers wanted to use a
test that they took
after they made their hailage
they wanted to use that for the entire
year and it's like based on the payments
we're making we're like well if we're
trying to make improvements use that
money to do more testing and try to
figure out a program and you know can
you test the balance based on the field
that it came from based on cutting
and then also uh you know as kristin
mentioned
ndf digestibility
i say it was infrequently used there
were a few of our
of our nutritionist that valued that
input
and i think that's something yes it's an
add-on test it adds cost to the testing
pro
to the testing program but
if we're talking about trying to make an
impact on on our greenhouse gases our
methane production these cow burps
you know
if we need to make
an impact on that you know going with
the 30 hour ndf digestibility can go a
long way on how we're gonna how we can
formulate rations and make these impacts
and uh you know one thing you know that
was never used and of course we talk
about the forged digestibility
you know net we never saw anybody look
at the undigestable ndf fraction of
those forages and
to me that that has a great value you
know again if we're trying to look at
overall reduction of of these cow burps
of our of our methane production you
know we have to look at both fractions
what's digestible and how much
is undigestable because we're you know
we had some ideas on on undigestable
forage and how and phosphorus excretion
so
again you know
really that's why you know our feed
management program was looking at at
providing some financial assistance so
we could look have producers start
looking at these options
slide
so again fixing our cycle you know can
we reduce the import of nutrients in the
rations
again can we utilize more homegrown
forages
cropping strategies
using cover crops to meet forage needs
alternative crops so
brassicas and our grazing systems and
that and again flexibility you know
getting some flexibility in that ration
formulation using those custom mixes
versus a pelleted feed
trying to use zero added phosphorus
mixes
and sometimes
that's a a challenge as well and again
looking at completing these these
additional tests on on ndf digestibility
excellent
so now we're going to finish up a little
bit talking about you know how if you're
if you're a nutritionist and you're
interested in in um becoming a tsp or a
technical service provider to provide
this service or in pennsylvania we used
for our 592 implementation
we developed a training program where we
worked with nutritionists to
get
become what we called a pa
nrcs qualified plan writer so
uh yeah and this really started way back
in 2007
uh jenny isler
joe harrison from washington state
you know they looked at how were they
going to
incorporate feed management and so from
the eastern side of things you know
through the mid-atlantic
water program there's a big
collaboration between our lane grants
you know obviously these csr ees epa
nrcs and again we
they got the and this is before i got
involved but you know this group was
pulled together you know really to say
well how can we start using feed
management to make an impact on on water
quality and that
and what they ended up doing was they
they've had funding to offset the cost
so as
wave that carried out for
for nutritionists to become a tsp or our
plan writer was
they were able to
have that money too because
most of those requirements were
uh
arpis to be for those nutritionists to
be certified
through arpis under the feed management
program so to take those tests it was a
hundred dollars so
this group was able to find money and
provide a way for for tsps to take the
take the exam at no cost
so what we did in pennsylvania oh you
know and this is the snapshot of of what
jenny and i and
rebecca white did you know basically we
partnered with penn state's dairy
nutrition conference
and
we would and over time we did eight
locations you know we would do it at
their nutrition conference we also
went out to
you know central pennsylvania and other
places and
offered the opportunity for uh producers
to take the arps exam so i had a pretty
good uh i think we had a pretty good
participation rate overall almost 300
nutritionists participated and
you know we had 81 of the 98
nationally you know again this is uh
data from from several years ago but you
know when we looked at list 98 of the
people that were on the harpist list
81 of them had come through the the
program that that was being done in
pennsylvania
next slide
so uh seeing that you know we really
wanted so our state conservationist
denise coleman saw the benefit in in
feed management so she established the
feed management initiative and our goal
starting in 2011 was to have get at
least 50 applications and fund 50
contracts for feed management and we
were quite successful we had we ended up
contracting 49 dairy operations and four
beef farms to implement feed management
so in order now to implement feed
management we needed the
feed management plans we needed the
qualified plan writers so
jenny rebecca and i
would schedule plan writing workshops
which was a mandatory requirement for
this for the certified nutritionist we
will hold several of these
they would come up with a free event if
they would come in we would provide the
training
that they would need and then also
after they attended that workshop then
they would have
they would submit two sample plans
and then
they would be reviewed by myself here at
nrcs and what we
ended up with
back then was was 24 qualified
nutritionists so we had 24 that were
qualified to all of them were qualified
to write dairy feed management plans and
uh we had five people that went through
to become qualified to write feed
management plans for beef operations
uh so our you know our requirements was
yet
anybody that was going to write feed
management plans had to be a member of
our fist harpist
and um and then they also had an mou
with nrcs so
to kind of host and provide these
trainings and you know other states
across the country do have
had other routes available
so the biggest thing is whatever state
you're in if you're interested in
becoming a plan writer you have to look
at their at their what they require as
far as training and experience and
credentials but other states did have
the non-office route
pretty much was a five-step process for
feed measure plans for anybody that once
wanted to become a a plan writer again
you had to attend the feed management
certification workshop that we commonly
did at the
their nutrition conference uh then at
the end of that we would also we'd give
them the opportunity to take the office
exam right there
we proctored the exam form
once they passed and got the results
back from arpas then we would hold our
plan writing workshops again
they would get all the tools that they
needed to complete those plans and then
those two plans would be submitted for
for review and approval and at that time
we had we gave him the option to become
an actual dsp through our
our
at the end it was our tech reg site now
it's been updated and revamped and now
it's called our nrcs registry
but for our implementation process
you know all we were requiring that our
plan writers were pa and rcs qualified
so step one again we had these locations
uh jenny did a great job at promoting
this through penn state's website um so
that workshop typically was at the dairy
nutrition conference uh it was about a
four hour training that we put on
and then the exam but official but
essentially what we're doing is
presenting the information that they
needed to know
uh for in preparation for taking that
exam
next slide
again they have become a member of arpas
again pass one exam so either dairy
nutrition
uh we went through some exam questions
kind of give a prop
prep them for what was going on in order
for them to take the exam
next slide
there we go then we had a as i said we
had our plan writing workshops again we
gave them all the tools they needed
plenty of opportunity to ask questions
and we would actually work through them
and you can see the one picture in a
previous slide jenny and i
they bring their laptops and we would
just have a work session after lunch for
them to complete a plan
thanks a lot
again
once they are ready to take their
attempt becoming a certified
certified or qualified
plan writer i would review those plans
and then
send them a letter
and then if they wanted to become a tsp
we would
get them set up with with
you know one of the things that uh we
did find out back then was that was the
big roadblock for uh nutritionists to
become an actual tsp because at the time
they would actually have to go into an
usda service center present their id to
get
access to the government system to take
uh different trainings that were
required for tsps and that was a major
roadblock and
our ag learn system was it's kind of
clunky we couldn't really set up
training plans and that was a big big
deterrent so i think that's one of the
reasons why uh when if you go on the
nrcs registry site now
i did look there's a lot of names on it
i'm not quite sure uh how they got there
but anyway
at at before we went to nrcs registry
when you went to tech reg that's why you
would only you might only find a handful
of people that were actually psps is
because of the process that it would
take to become a a tsp through our
registry system
so assistance for the producer uh
obviously we'd have their our qualified
nutritionists and then um you know again
now if we do have
you know we haven't contracted any plans
for several years now so
uh our our list is under review because
i'm not sure out there who's out there
that still is interested in writing
writing feed management plans
thanks a lot so uh just to kind of show
what kind of values out there where nrcs
can provide some assistance for
producers so i'm looking at last year's
uh we're still working on our fiscal
year 22
cost list but again for a producer that
wanted to do feed management
implementation
you know we were paying
about 2800 per group per year and
essentially you could do up to five
groups
uh for up to three years you had your
choice you could do one group for one
year or you could do five groups for
three years
so yeah as you can see it was uh you
know pretty enticing um
amount of financial assistance to do
that obviously our our under our hu
stands for historically underserved
producers so those
are our
limited and beginning farmers and then
our different
diverse
groups of farmers
next slide so again what makes up a feed
management plan we get the benchmark
plan developed by our our plan writer
and then we have a plan for each group
we get the lab analysis for everything
that's being fed
that those labs had to be
so we had manure testing so
the
labs that were testing the manure had to
be to be accredited by penn state
or or the university of pennsylvania and
again our plan had to show what
adjustments were needed and then follow
up on what was actually implemented at
the farm
and again
you know looking for those dietary
adjustments in that plan
next slide and then one other option we
had was our our cap plans our
conservation activity plans they have
now been changed to a different format
now but in the sake of time we won't
really get into that but
if a producer only wanted a benchmark
plan just to see what was going on the
farm but wasn't ready for implementation
they could get what we call this
conservation activity plan and that's
basically a benchmark evaluation so
one thing that we found
as far as nrcs
rules go you have to be
those plans have to be written by a tsp
so unfortunately
we have to date we have not funded any
of those because again we have no tsps
currently to do this so
something that we're we're looking at
hopefully changing in the years to come
but you know not a bad payment just to
get a benchmark evaluation of what's
going on in the farm and where there's
potentials for improvement
so just in summary looking at
implementing them you know so if you're
a nutritionist or somebody that's
interested in actually helping farmers
uh
implement feed management you know
within your state find out who your nrcs
feed management specialist is
find out what those requirements are
work with our tsp coordinators uh to
become a tsp or our nscs person to be
what i call a qualified plan writer and
again there's those trainings that have
to be done and some sample plans and
then once you're once you're certified
to go you know that's where we can start
helping that farmer implement a feed
management plan and then again for the
farmer
looking at um
these numbers are going to change for
for fiscal year 22 but you know again
financial assistance available for nrcs
for either that benchmark plan or
or the actual implementation of a feed
management plan the biggest thing is
for the implementation plan those funds
were to cover the cost of the plan
development and the implementation costs
which could you know so those funds were
meant to cover
potential increases and rationing costs
additional testing fees equipment
maintenance
whatever was needed to make those
improvements in the overall reduction of
nutrients
excreted on the farm
looks like
so you know the the bottom line here is
you know we think that our existing feed
management program based on water
quality
does have the
the potential to make an impact in
greenhouse gas emissions
on the farm you know a few tweaks in our
system but you know we're gathering i
feel that we're gathering enough infra
baseline information that uh you know if
if a state or
a farm is interested in trying to
trying to use feed management you know i
think we have a a great starting point
of of where we can do that but again if
you're interested in being a tsp contact
your state tsp coordinator again if
you're a farmer listening in today and
you're interested in financial
assistance or developing a feed
management plan contact your local nrcs
field office and again
you know bottom note here's chances are
you know as things are changing with
regulations
and and that
more funding could be coming along to
support feed management so again again
if you're if you're a producer start
thinking about it now are there some
strategies
that we've kind of talked about here
this morning that you could implement on
your farm
you know obviously
hopefully i've pre-divided enough
information to show you that you can do
some simple things to see improve
improve water quality improve you know
milk production and productivity your
farm
hopefully lower your bottom line a
little bit
and again reduce those overall
greenhouse emissions on the farm so
uh with that uh be willing to take any
questions if we have time i know i'm a
little bit over time but um
so if there's any questions we'll go
with that uh thank you so much for
attending today taking the time to
listen in
thank you dan so much for joining us can
you see the q and a questions
uh let me minimize the
minimize the pole
i cannot see the q a yet
um
all right um
so
jacob fox asks are any of these systems
you are describing brazing systems or is
it mostly cows and barns and food is
brought to them
most of
the farms that participated in
our feed management program
were confinement operations we did have
some grazing operations we did of those
couple beef contracts
most of those beef operations were
grazing operations we only had one b
feed lot operation
and we did have another larger farm
that
was about 50 50 50 emr 50 crazy
uh dan does nrcs consider fully
grass-based dairy systems as an improved
conservation system especially in terms
of climate smart and friendly production
so for instance would csp or equip
support grass-based dairy systems
um
i
i think we do uh especially you know
through our equip funding and that
we've always supported uh improvement of
grazing especially producers that are
looking to convert
cropland into permanent pasture
that's one of our our biggest things is
when we start
using financial assistance to help uh
fund and improve grazing systems you
know we're
you know we look at
converting
perennial crop land
into perennial perennial pastures so yes
we have had participants that uh have
converted some of their cropland to
pasture and we've also had participants
that
as long as their animal numbers
supported it converted their entire
operation to a grass-based farm with our
with our assistance
okay so kevin said i used to be a
nutritionist and dmi was whatever the
cows were eating it wasn't something
that you could control
if they ate 52 pounds dmi
that is what you balanced for how do you
reduce to 48 pounds you can't just limit
feed them can you how do you actually
get the dmi down
so what we were looking at was
formulation so
obviously
the
the quality of the feed is what was was
lim which was impacting dmi over time so
yes you know you can't automatically
without getting into yeah limit feeding
in that which we didn't promote
whatsoever um
no so we were looking at
you know
yeah tracking those
you know the rations and seeing you know
how what improvements could be made to
improve dry matter intake so again you
know looking at forge forge quality
would actually
be able to if you could make a change in
forage quality you should be able to
make a be able to make an impact in
overall dry matter intakes
obviously climatic things also impact
dry matter intake as well
okay
and augustine asked the question which
might be complicated
um
uh have you actually seen any research
studies connecting reductions in end
excretions through feed management plans
with reductions in greenhouse gases
meaning n2o in this case or connecting
some of the variables you talked about
and feed efficiency muncp in the diet
etc with greenhouse gas emissions
uh myself personally
no and that's what we found and that's
why as far as water quality we didn't
focus a lot on on nitrogen because
that's the hard one to quantify because
obviously uh you know there's really no
way to account for the nitrogen from
urine
and again
you know yes we could on our our grab
samples you send them out for analysis
you get that uh ammonium nitrate
uh
test in in
on that on your test result so but
now some of the feed programs uh like
cncps and and
the other program you know the models
that they look at model you know the
models will give you an idea of of
potential reductions but
no i am not aware of any specific
research that can tie
tie that together
thank you so much dan for joining us
today and thank you for all of our
participants who who joined us our next
webinar will be in december 16th and it
will focus on uh forest systems and
greenhouse gases
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu